another summer of agony in lebanon
the explosion of a fuel tanker and the
northern town of clay has added to an
already tense situation for millions of
lebanese
people are in disbelief
i consider this beirut's second
explosion what happened is not small
people have been incinerated some are
still missing god knows how many this is
a crime and i think every criminal every
smuggler is a traitor
i wanted to run away there were hundreds
gathered there right next to the tank
god only knows what happened to them
the explosion happened when lebanese
army personnel were distributing fuel
after discovering a hidden fuel tanker
that contained thousands of liters
medical teams in the area have been
overwhelmed
most of the injured had to be
transferred to neighboring cities for
treatment
in a country with no functioning
government a devastated economy and a
dire health situation a fuel crisis is
now leading to hours of waiting at
petrol stations i've been here for a
couple of hours i'll probably stay for
three four hours in order to fill my
tank with some petrol i'm not the only
one here
thousands of cars
not just where i am but everywhere in
lebanon are curing in front of petrol
stations to get a basic commodity
that no one can reach
i've been waiting for two hours i'm not
even sure whether i'll be able to get
petrol or not
i've been here for five hours
look it's empty i might wait another
three or four hours
every month i go through this five or
four times
lebanon has been through challenges in
the past but many say what they are
experiencing now political economic and
social unrest will be difficult to
overcome
aliyah al-jazeera thai southern
development